to uh sort this out myself but you know
I want to move on.
Hello. Hello madam. Hello. Hello.
Hello. What's the problem?
Yes. Um sorry. My name is Nami Michaela.
Um, basically um the council said I'm
not allowed to um come there anyway, but
I'm still basically I'm still with them,
but I'm still waiting for my oyster uh
my freedom pass and they haven't got
back to me about that. Um you need to
Yes. Yes. That's not Madam Madam. Madam
Madam, where's the root? Madam, I'm not
done.
Madam, let me finish. Let me finish. I
don't want that. Don't let the bookie
sort that out. Who told me not to talk
to me now? Look, look, look. Madam, I'm
not finished. Madam, I'm not finished.
Madam, so basically I need um I'm going
to come back everywhere, but you know, I
need them to move me. I'm going to write
an email uh for them to put me back in
the room in social care. I don't care
where they put me. I need to come back
to Dark. Uh because um just because I'm
I don't know why I'm in, you know.
Madam, madam, madam. Uh basically, I'm
going to come back to Torak. Um uh but
you know because um because I am uh
because I'm trying to come back to th I
don't want to be in no more uh because
they don't want to give me house because
I know th better and it's not working in
because I don't have my video bus so I
can't sort things out. I'm going to
write an email but then just chase it up
in the morning. Okay.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Okay. onto other matters.
So basically guys um today um uh I want
to introduce you guys to the writer's
framework or historical council. Uh
basically this is the aura seal. Uh
first of all this is the aura seal. See
this image this ebook pattern 3. Uh this
called an aura seal. So it's basically
um the the thing I've been talking
about. Uh but it's basically like a
drawing uh for patterns everything. Uh
now we got this one.
Basically this this is about the writers
framework in my heart. This is like um
this land is all mine. this scribbling.
Uh, but this is what I've been
practicing um on my art book. Uh, some
of them I didn't really do, but I'm
going to show you guys. This is really
fun for you guys to see cuz I'm really
good at it. Uh, but I'm not really that
good at it. Just trying to find the um
uh basically this is me practicing. Uh,
so you got here um something. So you got
like stage one to stage one to uh it's
about form. This is the last stage. The
box falling the floor. Uh so you got
like uh stage one uh uh circle perfect
uh faces ovals slinky uh and then we got
like cub boy the deform shape and then
uh an atomy part and and some folk
notes to me. Uh this is lollipop girl.
Basically it's a really beautiful girl.
Uh but you know she's kind of so
beautiful that she's dangerous cuz
everyone might want her but no woman
commo
she's um she's a hoe
the the four three and a
b you take a 43 uh and you write upside
down flip upside down that's what that
is um but you know this is this like
antichrist uh uh antichrist Japanese
home this for zod
uh you can find this on medium.com but
you know Um the story if goes uh Zia is
S uh X I A on space regret devil's deal.
Uh this is very important for me. This
like uh the story about Zia a devil
worshipper. She has everything but she
wants more power. She wants um uh
universal power. She wants to able to
like go into the demon realm and do
stuff to the demons. But you know she
starts to power and her dad mama king.
They're monarchs. Uh they're Chinese um
and Japanese. uh but not Chinese because
that's Chinese history. So you know
Japanese and they want um Jia is very
rich but she's very agreed with power.
She wants to be the the most powerful
person in the world because you don't
think mom and dad are doing well with
the power making everything normal good
for everyone just she's evil basically I
love basically I love evil evil stuff.
Uh this one is um uh this is incibility.
So basically this for like um the I
still got it inspired by the people. So
basically this means king and this goes
down. See this king uh that's king. The
cross is like the um uh king or child to
become a king. Child adult in king. So
this like see this one. So basically
this means child to adult to king cuz
I'm a n king cuz my dad want to crown
me. But I'm a real king for real guys.
I'm not joking to you. Just my dad is
useless. Um um so this is the one. Uh so
this is like a proep here. This is a
king. But it's like a pattern for it. So
this one's king. This one's going back
to the country. this like a sibly um so
this about like iconography but about
the really icons but all are symbols but
symbols are just etchings so there's a
relationship you know so like I can just
draw a symbol um but a symbol won't mean
anything it's just an etch I can just
draw but you the go giving me making me
something so referral system matching
time uh then we got um this uh thing
here
oh basically I wanted wings so I myself
wings
So this wing basically but this like one
wing type it's like if I spread it out
but this is for like actually um this is
called um this was actually for
something called um another basically
this art was called um what's the
article piece called
uh this RP was called um wingman. So
basically you see this wing this wing is
like a resition of like someone that's
really OP uh you know in in CQB uh close
quarters combat. So see if you know CQB
you know there's a song called a wingman
and that person also
uh the corner so it's like corner slicer
but you know that person has a very
important job and that's to kill um uh
your eye to side cuz we can turn 180 180
but that's not enough uh when you are in
close combat it's like it's narrow it's
like it's too much to do it's like you
know and the wingman is just um your
field of view over uh 180° uh but you
know you are basically looking straight
you
uh not straight, but you're looking like
in between 180 uh 90° um uh but you
don't really cover the whole um uh let's
say 125 uh 90 to 125 degrees, but you
don't cover everything cuz you don't. So
the wingman cover the rest cuz you know
they'll get a gun and they go by your
side and it's like a tag team. So
basically they they clear out the the
hard corners like you know uh for
example this is a basically say someone
um in that like say this like this is a
corner here. This is corner here. Let me
just show you guys. See this corner. So
there's four walls here. Uh one corner
here, one corner here. My bed is another
corner here. See that corner? Uh four
walls, you know. Uh now one left and so
basically uh if I want to go from here
um I position what I mean uh into that
door uh into that door there uh uh this
corner. I cut this I go to this corner
here. This corner here uh and then I say
okay now I slice. Now this is now this
person is like uh uh that corner there
is like the entrance like the is like
someone going in. So basically cuz I'm
going out I want to go out. I I then
turn and shoot. Um but the wingman's job
is to make sure that all my other angles
are covered you know cuz I can shoot
there and he can shoot me and I die. But
the wingman can like um pick this corner
here. So I don't have to I keep going
straight. You know it's kind of weird
but you know I just keep going where I
want to go. That's called a point man.
So you got a wingman and a point man. Uh
this like a wing wingman. Uh the winged
man. The wingman. Uh the wingman is a
drawing. Uh and this like a a giraffe.
This is draft. I don't know what I call
this like a a bird. No, no. This called
a freedom bird. Draft one. I call it
freedom board. Uh this is a freedom bird
one.
Uh,
and this is like uh the wing. I need a
wing uh span. Like you know, I'm
actually trying to lift the wing.
Basically, it's like a wing or trying to
lift it. It's like I'm lifting the wing.
You see this? What I should be doing?
Like I should be lifting the wig. Uh
this like um some lady some man lady.
It's not me. This is a very dood. But um
I'm going to get back to it. One second.
One second. Let me just come back to it
right now. Uh before I just make a video
now. I'll make a video later about this
artwork. But uh and this is Ezami. This
is King Nambi because this like I'm a
king in Nigeria. This is an avatar of my
I'm trying to make uh for my YouTube
channel. Uh but you know the avatar is
going to be there forever. Basically
Nambi is gonna be talking to Ezi Nambi.
So basically this is Nambdi. No this
Nambdi meaning king in my country. So
he's a king. He's wearing an EO crown
almost everything. Uh and then this is
um
so basically you see this this is
greatness in the making. This is my
glasses everything. Uh he's smart
everything. No, no, sorry. This is a No,
no. This is king. See the crown? That's
a crown and that's a feather. It's like
a basically it's a symbolic meaning. You
got a three feathers. Basically, a chief
has two feathers. He has three feathers
for uch e and me obi. So, it's kind of
like that. You got an e crown, got the
glasses, and you got the hair, you got a
beard. Uh this is called a sketch. Uh
let me just show you this. Uh
let's just brighten. Uh okay. So that's
like a king. So you can go through it
again myself. I go to you guys. So I do
it to myself. So basically um and this
my uh can board uh that's not double
track the other one for the other but
this is Uber's data uh oriented pattern
uh applications. This was one I make in
a long time. Uh but you know it's like
uh I'm just show you guys actually did
it. You know it's it's meant to be.
Okay. Then now this is the freedom bird
here.
Um demon
basically this is a freedom bird. It
flies free. It's called a freedom bird.
You never see it. Never fly. It's like
you never see it fly cuz the head is so
m shaped. It's like I'm looking at you
but it's weird. You know it's a freedom
bird. It's like a very It's like a
freedom. See the winker in is perfect. I
got it perfectly right. It's flying
perfectly but the head is kind of funny.
It's a bird. Well, it won't be funny.
Uh, but that's what I'm saying to you
guys. So, basically guys, I'm showing
you guys I made this IP work. Uh, so you
guys can look. Oh, you can't draw
nothing. I don't care what you say and
draw, right? Just draw. Uh, okay. So,
guys, um, it's for me to just uh reflect
on myself, not you. That's my YouTube
channel. It's just my my inner
monologue, my thoughts. Okay. So, Nami,
why you showing yourself this? So,
basically, so Nami, so basically Nami,
uh, so basically this is the this for
the organism. just going to be clear
this is the um first of all this is a uh
for the writer's framework uh keep
saying writer's framework but you know
the writer's framework is this anyway so
basically got a doodle uh which is just
a do question that doesn't mean anything
basically got level zero this is level
zero this a child's drawing uh you got
this catch uh this sketching like level
one like the sketch you know the the
form uh you given to some object form
you know and you got the authentic
pressure like um is he me is he no he
got the no I got I expression. Okay.
Basically, you got the authentic
expression. Yeah. So, this level two
like authentic expression in the in the
biome where you are like who you are,
what you expressing. Uh this uh this
like uh symbol like then you got um
basically you got level zero which is a
do you can do anything. Level two one is
catch. Uh level two is what authentic
expression want to express like um like
someone falling, someone dying, sanders
emotion. Uh mine was based on verb noun
verb noun pairs like you know uh the
verb noun concept modeling that uh puts
into the uh 3x3 um like you know uh uh
like the golden ratio proportions
everything how how that depicts the what
the emotion I want to give what I want
to show to people about uh whatever I'm
depicting
uh then you got uh authentic uh
craftsmanship soaric or cultural
expression so it doesn't have to be
cultural can be symbolic can mean to you
mean to you and you got um authentic
craftsmanship
uh authentic craftsmanship. So so
authentic craft on level one. So goes
the pyramid gets harder and harder if
climb the pyramid level one uh doodle uh
level zero doo level one's catch level
two uh level three uh level four is a
question uh the craft. So basically I
can take that idea everything and make
it like a 3D game. or make it like a 3D
model you know uh for example the
freedom bird I can take it out and make
it a freedom bird in the world give some
meaning you know make it like a product
or something like that that's what level
four is authenticationship and you got
um sovereign car like sovereign means
like the soul or the biome it fits into
the ecosystem like has a theme ecosystem
so sovereign like sovereignty it belongs
there it's not an ar it's bas basically
it's based on the world like you know we
humans live in earth but it's like a roy
is like in world is is weird but you
know if I'm a human in royald
world um if a human royal is normal
because there's the story align with
everything so this has the sovereign
with sovereignty and that's what makes
it um the heart and the soul philosophy
the soul the soul heart obi heart or
soul this is one two zero one two three
four five for five and five is mentor
six is mentor so mentor can teach anyone
can teach everyone about sovereignty
uh about your origin, my BF history, my
BF history, um like who I am, how how I
treat people. And then you got um
symbolic activist uh uh symbolic
activist. It's like activist symbolic um
like oh so basically
so basically level one 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
level seven is a sovereign like
sovereign states. You b that biome. part
of that t that makes you buy a part
where you live it's sovereign that's the
art that belongs there that's a culture
that's the meaning of symbols and then
you got the sovereign symbolic activist
you got the um basically level eight is
symbolic it means something you know you
know symbolic uh it's universal uh it
belongs to everyone anyone can notify it
it's symbolic um but it's symbolic can
activate
I'm trying to uh create new knowledge of
art and culture I'm trying to create new
symbols uh like that me origin
my own business and thing and symbolic
um sovereign activist like the
sovereignty of it is it so basically
again this is part of the writer
framework it's called basically the
right framework um really about this you
got the sovereign activist like being
sovereign to yourself who you are
basically for me um uh see all this
clothes I'm wearing it's all boring it
doesn't mean anything to it's just like
plain there's no innovation uh my
personas it doesn't maintain it doesn't
mean anything it's just like charity
close it doesn't mean anything. So this
is just um your framework uh which is
also part of writing. This is like your
creative writing framework. It's like a
uh how you uh um try to inci um and
incidi language model uh which is like
um the the framework behind the writing
uh but it's like for drawing uh mainly
for drawing this just part one for you
but your goal is to have this um pyramid
uh uh universal to the ordinary product
so we can have authentic clothes
authentic garments authentic wear you
know uh for it so it can use to draw
it's called drawic uh because anyone
that draws is called the Anyone that
draws is a drawer. Anyone that writes is
a writer. But what makes make them a
writer? A writer is a drawer. Basically,
you cannot I'm saying that it's part of
writing because you cannot draw without
writing for me because you know you have
to plan your writing because you plan
you still write on paper and this. So
basically the drawing framework is like
literally drawing and writing. So this
is part of the writing part called
framework or the artist framework. Um
the goal is to have this universal. Uh
so this is like uh the the thing I'm
creating for the uh authentic uh
conscious mitigation conscious
integration mitigation like you know uh
being sovereign being part of a
community being part of something uh
authentic arts that last and last and
last things that mean something symbolic
things uh that mean something uh uh
basically um basically I'm going to try
video on the draws from it but this one
I'm saying to you it's it's authentic
it's it's you soul Uh I use a lot for a
lot of uh writing to do it. Um because
I'm a writer too and a drawer. I don't
care what I draw or the picture. It's
just uh beautiful um to me. Uh but you
know the goal here is to show um this
just like someone looking up in the sky
like a robot. But that's me.
Uh yep. Uh
uh it's about uh sovereignty. It's like
uh who you are. But this is basically um
one more thing Nambdi to tell them to
tell your people. So basically since
this is this is hella complicated uh but
this is basically you see this one here
or this art here uh anyone in OB anyone
working with your framework must
understand uh this is basically this
this is uh level zero automatically it's
just a doodle why why is a doodle it
can't be uh it can't be a sketch
it can't be a sketch uh because it
doesn't mean so the metric how you mark
this so because freedom bird the flying
birds with a wing uh the wing is looking
up uh tries to look up right right you
know it's flying above is basically it's
like a looking up at a bird and has
wings. Uh this is basically saying that
the do it's a dudo. Yes. Why? Because
everything's at level zero. If you if
you think you're level two, uh you know,
basically this is not expression on my
soul. It's it's a freedom. Yes, I see a
freedom. But the freedom word freedom
doesn't mean anything if I don't have
the um other one the art like the like
the meaning like the like the what I
call the um po one. Basically, if I have
a poem with this as well. So, this this
bird freedom bird has a poem. So, I can
make a poem right now. Like the bird was
free. It flew over. It never understood
anything but freedom and freedom was his
name. Uh that poem alone just gives you
like uh the freedom bird, you know, but
that people will not know it's a freedom
bird. So, basically your goal is to um
take uh let me try to write the phone
properly. Uh let me just stop this
video. Basically your goal is to So
guys, anyone working with my framework
um level 0 to uh nine
uh the freedom free free was the bird
free uh wishes
wishes uh wishes which
uh free will the bird
flock
flocking Three
block
guys to make a poem right now to see how
this works. So basically guys, I'm
making a poem right now. So I want you
guys to bear with me. So basically go to
Freedom Bird everything. Uh this is
called the Freedom Bird. um uh emotion
uh basically this is something called
emotion pivots and crisis. So emotion um
emotion means like uh a motive um uh you
know basically the emotion crisis for is
like um it's like um if you go to my
medium post I'm going to try to use it
but you know uh let me try to find it
actually guys um so basically I I'm just
using my explicit I'm trying to kind of
find it like um here oh no you know it's
like a
so basically this should be like um you
know it's like you know locked somewhere
It should be locked in now.
Uh
so basically
so basically this is my uh medium. Uh
I'm looking for something called um uh
crisis uh purpose and emotion. I should
be here in my uh repository. I didn't
plan this is like the other ones. The
other one uh crisis um
uh so basically oh it's called Z
regrets. Uh so yes this is zest regret
please look at this but this is what the
the thing is. So you got like the BFR
pattern, the P one uh the private key
here. See this private key? That's the B
pattern. The P one, the public key and
the avatar uh the basically you got the
uh uh P the public key and art protocol.
But this is like um a pattern because
you know the B pattern is like B of
butterfields the private key you got the
P which is art protocol and the fracture
but you don't want to about this. This
is where the art really is you know and
then you can use it for something else
if it works in the real world um which
is how it is. So basically see Z regrets
um before you go um this is just like uh
the crisis um see this one. So basically
I'm trying to create one for the um show
don't tell. So this is a poem uh poem is
like um a poem a pro is not a poem
because I'm saying to you I can be
poetic but a pros is like me saying to
someone else I can sing to someone else.
This a pros. So basically I can say sing
about Juliet my wish for Juliet but if
it's about Juliet um where you know even
one sent one word of Juliet Romeo and
Juliet you will learn my lover that's a
pros because it's not it's not a poem
because you're not singing about
yourself. You can say I'm falling in
love with a beautiful woman but you
cannot say Juliet or like um her name
because that says she's an example. Uh I
love her but you can say I love women
but you don't understand why you love
women. So the difference between a poem
and a pros first of all is because the
poem is only you you you me myself and
I. You speak about your feelings who you
are but pro you speak about your love
your interest what you do um that's your
bas like a show don't tell. So basically
show don't tell you show the audience
this like part of the motion. So
basically character crisis relationship
uh internal conflict stakes uh in
certain incidents settings and um
setting. So basically this is just a uh
this is this model is a crisis pivots.
Um basically this is crisis that
happened in a story for example uh why
is there a freedom bird? Why is why does
a bird fly? What's the crisis? Why is it
free flock [ __ ] free? Why does want to
be part of a flock? You know what what's
the significance of having a freedom
bird? That's the crisis. But you know
it's based on trilogy. So the model of
this is like um really um uh like you
know you got like a forest but a forest
alternative is like uh creative um
formally. So alliteration uh uh fact uh
alliteration
uh uh alliteration uh facts and figures
uh uh onia wait
uh uh questions uh a motive language
uh basically this one's like um long
simile and met of and rule of threads
you know this like um for like non
creative writing like formal writing use
to um write to uh formal bodies uh but
is like a for techniques the techniques
cuz they're not using the same
specification but you know it's for
creative writing so this what I'm doing
for my uh English basically this right
is why it's part of right so good cuz
you know let me explain now so you got
the crisis uh crisis is like um
character your character is the heart of
a story reader must care about them uh
at root of them but never fear them so
basically the goal is this is like you
continue so you for everything you
create the freedom bird you create
uh you must care for them focus on each
character depth uh the quirks and
motivation uh for example my freedom
bird who is my freedom bird uh basically
the character must be like um itself you
know like I fly I can't say basically
instead of me saying um um so this how
you use the framework properly so
basically I got to do properly so I am I
am free I am free flock so there's a
bird speaking and that's a po one I am
free of flock
I'm free of the flock. Free.
I am free of the flock. You know, free
bird, freedom bird
in my kingdom. In my king
with my
shoulder.
Okay. Basically with my wisdom with my
wisdom
I I build
I am my own kingdom.
Basically the kingdom is like the birds
fly around. Basically it flies itself.
It's free. It's it's it own you know
that's example I'm giving you guys. So
it's a freedom bird. I'm calling it a
freedom bird. But the idea of this is
for you to understand this framework. Um
so this is like the writing here. I am
free um um uh basically if you try to
put this narrative chip in here. So
basically you just try to do it now. Oh
my battery my battery is going to die.
My battery going to die. Sorry guys.
This scares me man. It it just pumps my
heart up like
so basically I'm trying to do this now.
Uh it's about you using what you know
about what you see observing the world
and making I am free of the flock with
my wisdom like the wisdom being dumb. Uh
dumb means like kingdom I am my own
kingdom
you know. Uh and then let me just give
you I'm not going to do the whole thing.
Of course I'm not going to do the whole
thing. Be long. Uh then that's just the
character and it gives everything has
there and then other one that's a motion
that's the motion basically the motion
is like driven
so basically um what's the motive of the
character why are they free what do they
want it's like problem statement um
explanation what do they want um so
basically the obstacle they must
overcome is basically based on the you
see like the the the beginning middle
and end trilogy uh is based on something
called the the the the
Basically in all cultures guys there's
something called um
in all stories in all stories like
there's something called narrative like
narative I've got a hero hero journey or
the heroin's journey um but the
heroine's journey is like um the same
thing so this just the same thing
beginning and there's a happy ending and
we got like movies about them you know
that's what the media come from you know
they tell the story in pictures you know
moving pictures which are movies uh or
animation Uh so you got motivation
obstacle theme.
So this like uh basically the motivation
one one my purpose is uh uh free to act
free
to judge me not judge me not uh uh so
what's my question to free cuz you know
it feels limited it feels confined by
the flock free to act
free to act to be free to act Uh
uh basically you also define so it
obscures like um the um free to act
uh free
from judgment I'll come to um
curiosity
is my wisdom
basically it's curious and that's
supposed to be free
uh I build
Uh basically the wisdom, the kingdom.
Uh I am the um basically um I build I am
I build my own kingdom. Oh basically I
build my own kingdom.
I build one second. One second. Let me
try. Okay. I'm trying to make it better.
Uh city is my wisdom. I build my own
kingdom. I am my own kingdom.
I
I met uh quick my uh wisdom. Met
metamorphosize meta
move
um move to wisdom.
So basically I'm I am free uh of the
flock. With my wisdom, I build my own
kingdom. Uh, free to act. Free from
judgment. Curiosity is my wisdom.
I move. I I move. I transform. Uh, I
move.
I move. Uh, I move. Um,
I move.
Sovereign sovereign sovereignty
I
declare my sovereignty basically I I
declare uh my sovereignty like you know
my freedom
I declare my freedom
uh I declare my sovereignty
I am
free
basically that's basically see this one
is beginning, middle and end. So, I'm
teaching you how to guys how to do um
arting thing. Uh this like um the and
how to add rhythm. So, basically this is
just the this like the mind map for Z
regress. Uh you can check that out. But
you know Z1 was like um uh animation. Uh
then we got um uh so that's crisis. The
last one this like one I did for SIA the
stanza but that's in haiku. Uh so
basically uh pivots emotion
crisis uh piv basically the this is like
um uh crisis the crisis that happens the
pivots the change and then uh the motion
is like the resolution. Um so basically
the mission I am the I am the I am okay
free okay basically I have to say
something I am free of the flock
uh uh with my wisdom I build my kingdom
free to act free uh judge uh free of
judgment
free of judgment curiosity is my wisdom
I declare my sovereignty
free a free and the free uh free is the
flock.
Uh
as free
as freedom
can be
I am the freedom bird.
I am I am the freedom. So this like um
the poem now you see this crisis uh
pivot emotion I'm going to talk about
something else um but the writer's
framework I'll come to the other one
this just the let me quot so this one
here I'm going to try to read out to you
uh uh live not life so this one here so
I am it's like the about the bird kind
of thing so basically you see here so
let's see so this like the art I drew
and there's a reason why I drew it is
like because of this uh so basically you
can look at this first uh here I can't
really show you. This is some paper, but
it's like weird and it's like dirty. Uh,
but you know, that's what I'm think. So,
you got to remember, uh, this a doodle.
This a doodle. Uh, but the doodle is
like, uh, the last one, but this
everyone's basically everyone's at level
zero. Unless they, uh, if you think
you're level, if you try to draw level
three, uh, level one, two, uh, you're
zero because if it's just peer review,
your work, anything, you doing business
with anyone, uh, but you're level zero
automatically because you don't have
like, um, a thing expression. This your
expression. Uh but it's a doodle. Um
it's still a doodle and a sketch. So you
are either um doodling or or sketching.
But you don't this my expression. I
think I'm a level two. Uh but there's
other reasons to suggest I'm not level.
You have to think of other reasons
basically. So basically this freedom
bird is level zero. Let me think. It
could be level zero because he's just
outline. There's no actual um sketching
uh not sure form. But I can argue
there's more form than in doodle because
doodle is just boring stuff. Gives no
form. It's more abstract. So this I
would say this a level one but is it
authentic? Oh yeah it's like me. I am
free. Um so I would say I'm level two.
Yes. Level two. So this level two piece
of uh uh this level of freedom bird. So
it does match level two. Uh level one uh
level zero level one. Level two uh of
the authentic expression. This my
authentic expression. Now the po one
here is other one. So this is the
freedom bird.
I am free of the flock. Um I'm free of
the flock. With my wisdom I build my own
kingdom.
Free are to act. Free from judgment.
Curiosity is my wisdom. I declare my
sovereignty. Is that what it is? Free is
the flock. As free as freedom can be. I
am the freedom bird.
You get it? Freedom bird. So that's one
thing. So this thing is this level
three. But now this like a public key to
my artwork example. So if you go up to
the top uh so basically there's copy
infringement everything. So this is a
private key here. This will be the
freedom birth here. Uh the private key
is the freedom birth. Now the public key
I can give everyone the pool one is a
public key and that's the R protocol.
Now it's sample proof 2.5 percentile 0%.
If I see infringement on this work I can
sue anyone. Uh but you know that's our
protocol. The public key it shows to
everyone. It's free to see. But the poem
I can give to anyone but that's
interpreted because they cannot
interpret something that's very abstract
like that. So if I give someone this
poem, they see it as an art protocol.
They don't understand and then they try
to decipher it and they say, "Oh, what
did you draw?" But if I give someone a
poem and show them the art um I can
basically I can clear two poems. I can
give what this freedom bird means to me.
And they say, "Why did you create it? I
created a freedom bird uh because um
because I created a freedom bird because
I want to express myself." Yes. But you
know the poem here uh two I can give
them one poem uh everyone to see. I can
give them a little poem uh keep one
poem. So if there's any copyright
infringement, they see the freedom bird
and we and I say um if you go to court,
it's going to be a dispute. Uh so it's
going to be a problem. So the the the
the thing about this freedom bird is
that um the private it's a private key.
It's what it has to be. It has to be
separate. Uh it's going to be two to
one. It's like owner oral skill.
But the avatar is a basically uh if
there's an avatar basically this my
avatar. I'm the avatar. I'm the freedom.
I'm the freedom. you know uh because
triggers like the trigger uh is like um
I trigger something like you know the
trigger is like me uh if I'm angry I'm
the avatar basically this is my
alternate expression this is my persona
this is my trademark work uh and then
legal automation uh the basically the
computer can check this a computer can
check this uh basically goes to
franchise nodes uh computing publishing
and art uh computing open computing open
publishing uh book arts like it goes to
write industry it goes to do the goes to
solve the problem. It's going to
basically it's going to be authentic for
that scenario for that biome for where
you are. Uh which I'm saying to you uh
this one zero is regret this like Z one
uh color palette Japanese ornament. But
this is like she meets basically she has
the devil in her room. She's cursing the
devil overnight praying overnight. Uh
you can look at this read it out this
article and this like the thing uh I did
this a stanza. Um so that's the freedom
bird for you. It's better because it's
more authentic. Uh uh but you know
that's going to be copyright everything
if you want to see it. Uh it's level
two. I'm glad I achieved it cuz it's
like uh there's a it's not like I stop I
didn't stop it. I just did it well
enough to my ability and I and I'm happy
with that specificity um with that art
uh protocol. Uh so um am I done with
this video? Yes. So uh so basically what
you guys do is create something that um
basically built in infrastructure as a
service. So as um architecture as
infrastructure a a
you know that's architecture as
infrastructure because the architecture
is built into the design basically if I
want to design this for use anything you
can design like a light uh like a a
light lamp that floats in like like a
light bulb like it does this that look
like this um and build it because
basically my company is designed to
clean company um but that's idea you
sovereignty you have the soul in it you
have what you want in it. Um uh yes,
it's like uh it is like that. So your
goal is to have the sovereign. Uh
anything I forgotten? No. Okay, I'll go
back to Thank you for watching this
video. Uh like, share, and subscribe if
you want, but this is just me reflecting
on my work. Um
uh uh Dr. Sovereign uh and have a look.
Take care. Here we go. So YouTube just
actually just caps this and put this
properly. Um so this is like a like a
thumbnail or something. So it's going to
be look like this skele.
But guys, I should not lose this. So uh
again NDI uh uh level zero is a doodle.
Uh level one is a catch. Uh level two is
external expression. Uh which is this.
Level three is symbolic uh or cultural
expression. Level four is authentic
expression. Level five is a
craftsmanship. Uh uh level six is
mentor. Level seven is um symbolic
expression. Level eight is activist. Uh
you can activist anywhere you can
basically can access activist any biome
you're in you can just observe the world
everything okay take you this is part of
the draw uh let's call it the artist
framework